PATRICK LORTON:
Hi, I'm Pat Lorton.
I'm the CTO of Schrodinger,
a company many of you
may not have heard of,
working on problems
you also may not have heard of.
But I'm excited to talk
to you about both today.
I think there's a lot of
interesting stuff in there,
even for people who
aren't from the field.
So who is Schrodinger?
What do you do?
Those are going to be
the first questions.
We're an almost
30-year-old company
that is committed both
to fundamental research
and applying that research
to accelerate drug discovery
material design.
Our approach to
accelerating drug discovery
is to simulate chemistry
on the computer.
I imagine that's very
fascinating to a lot of people
in here.
And it allows us
to make predictions
about how drugs will
work in the human body
without ever having to
create those drugs in the lab
and test them until much
later in the process.
I won't have enough time today
to talk about materials design,
but there's also a lot of
really fascinating stuff
there from OLED
design to perfumes,
just tons of
fascinating chemistry
we're able to simulate
in those fields.
I will start with a quick
walk-through of the agenda.
One thing I really
want to state upfront
is I'm trying to
present in a way,
realizing that most people,
this field is completely novel,
and you don't know
anything about it.
So you don't have to know
about computational chemistry,
or even chemistry,
for that matter.
I'm going to try
to break it down
into the core
problems of computers.
But I will also
give some background
because otherwise it's
just not going to be
an interesting presentation.
So first, we'll start with,
why is drug discovery so
hard or expensive?
You've probably read about this.
Newspapers talk
about it all the time
when this new drug
comes out, and it
costs $200,000 for a cure for
something, and everyone says,
how can you charge that much?
They'll reference that it
costs billions of dollars
to discover the drug.
Why?
Why does it cost
billions of dollars?
So I'll start with that.
And then I'll go to
computational chemistry, which
is a field that is really more
than 50 years old at this point
but is seeing a renaissance
with modern compute.
I'll talk about
Schrodinger's solution, which
uses the cutting
edge computational
chemistry to solve
pharmaceutical problems.
And then from there,
after that background,
I'll go into the compute
requirements, the real meat
and potatoes, and
we'll figure out
what GCP is doing that's driving
our science and driving drug
discovery faster.
In that part, talking about how
GCP is speeding up Schrodinger,
I'll go through several things.
I'm not going to
read him off here,
but there are many ways that GCP
is really being helpful to us
as a company and as
the field in a whole.
So let's jump in with
this big, crazy number.
There are more than 10 to 60
potential drug-like molecules.
Some estimates go all the way
up to 10 to the 100th or 10
to the 120th.
That is just an
astronomically big number.
By some estimates, it's more
potential drug molecules
than there are atoms in
the entire universe, which
is hard to even fathom.
And we need to find the
best one for each disease.
That's a little bit strong.
It doesn't have to be
the absolute best one.
But we have to find a
really, really good one
for each disease.
And when you're looking at
that many potential drug-like
molecules, it's an
incredibly daunting task.
It's not a needle in a haystack.
It is not even an
atom in a haystack.
It's smaller than an
electron in a haystack.
That's how small
of a thing we're
looking for when we're
trying to find a good drug.
So why is drug discovery
as a whole so hard?
I just got into nearly
infinite chemical space.
That's one of the most daunting
tasks in preclinical drug
discovery when we're
looking for the right drug,
before we take it into
human clinical testing.
Accurate evaluation's
really hard.
Even if you make a guess.
If I just randomly am able to
pick the magical molecule out
of my head and make a perfect
guess, synthesizing that
in a lab costs somewhere
from hundreds to thousands
and, in some extreme cases,
even hundreds of thousands
of dollars, to produce that
molecule so you can test it.
So figuring out how to test
ideas faster and cheaper
can really bring down costs.
When you're saying, oh, let's
try to do it computationally,
the problems are extremely
computationally hard.
So it's a constant
negotiation between accuracy,
which we may never be
able to compute perfectly,
or something really,
really fast that
might have so low accuracy you
can't really make decisions off
of it.
So that's the pull and the
push in computational work.
And then if you do
all of that right,
if all your preclinical
work goes perfectly,
biology is also really hard.
Biology is where
drug design projects
start because you have to know
what biological target you're
going after.
And it's also where they
end because, when they're
going into the
clinic, you're really
testing whether the
chemistry works well
in the human biology.
And you had theories
going into it,
but your theories are
really just a hypothesis
until you've done large-scale
clinical trial testing.
And many, many-- the vast
majority of programs,
actually-- fail during
clinical testing.
So even if you do everything
perfect chemically,
which is really
expensive and hard,
you still stand a
decent chance of failing
because the fundamental
biology is wrong.
So that's why it's so
dang hard and expensive.
So what is
computational chemistry?
I won't bore you by
reading the entire thing.
And you probably
guessed by the name.
It's using computers to
make chemistry predictions.
It's an incredibly hard problem.
Without using numerical
analysis or clever estimations,
many chemistry problems
are more complex to solve
than the hardest
encryption algorithms.
We're talking, it is easier to
crack the hardest encryption
algorithm than it would be to
get the exact accurate answer
for a chemical question, which
is really, really daunting,
so we have to try to estimate.
The main goal of
this field, actually,
is to try to get as accurate
a solution as possible
with as fast of
estimations as possible.
Why is it so hard?
Well, again, we're going back
to the nearly infinite chemical
space.
The more predictions than
atoms in the universe,
if you take that
to the next step
when you're thinking
about the infinite space,
that means it is literally
impossible to store.
If you somehow could
calculate the perfect value
on every single one of
those, you couldn't even
store them because there's not
enough atoms in the universe
to put that data anywhere.
So you have to be really,
really clever in what you sample
and how you store it.
Accurate evaluation's
really hard.
What I was mentioning
a second ago
about how it can be more
difficult than an encryption
algorithm.
These are NP-hard problems and
very hard NP-hard problems.
Quantum computers may one
day crack some of them,
but there are a lot of problems
that are just not going
to be amenable to
quantum computers ever
just because of the nature of
the data and things like that.
Then you start talking
about how big--
If it's that hard for a
simple water molecule,
like I mentioned
here-- how big it is.
Proteins are actually huge.
So if it's so hard that
a quantum computer still
can't solve for a water molecule
or the fastest supercomputers
are having problems getting
valid values for a water
molecule, we're talking
hundreds of thousands
of atoms, orders of
magnitude larger than water,
that we need to be able
to accurately predict
to make a drug prediction.
Huge amounts of
science, 50 years,
have gone into accurately
estimating relatively cheaply.
And then the compute
is massive and uneven,
so that is something
that the cloud has really
helped a lot because, in certain
phases of a drug discovery
project, you might want
50,000 GPUs to be working
for a day or two to get you
an answer quickly so you
can drive decisions in the lab.
But then you'll have
a three-week synthesis
cycle in the lab where you just
don't need those GPUs at all.
And if you're at a big
pharmaceutical company,
you might be able to
balance it by having
so many projects
vying for that time,
but a huge amount of
fundamental drug research
is done at smaller
biotechs that don't
have that advantage of dozens
of active projects going on.
So I'm going to stop from
the more compute-intensive
description and do a
really quick science break.
I know most of you
won't know chemistry,
so this just looks like three
random pictures on the screen.
So let's pretend that our
brains are neural networks
and try to do some
pattern recognition here.
Solubility is one of the
most important properties
in drug design.
We've spent a huge amount of
resources trying to accurately
predict solubility.
Solubility, just as
a reminder, is simply
when you drop a drug in
water, will it actually
dissolve into the water?
If it doesn't dissolve into the
water, if it just sits there,
then what you have is
extremely expensive brick dust
because it will just
sit in your system
and go completely through
you without your body
ever absorbing it
and using the drug.
So you have to find
something that's soluble.
So looking at it from an image
recognition neural network,
these are 2D representations
of three different structures.
So let's try to guess the
third structure based on two
where we already
know the answer.
So the left one has
mediocre solubility.
It'll break down in water
a bit, but maybe not enough
for a drug to be effective.
The far right one
has no solubility.
It'll end up as chalk in
the bottom of your water,
and the middle one looks like
something between the two.
So it's really hard to guess.
Maybe it has a little better
solubility than the left one.
Maybe it has in between,
but from this data,
there's just not
much you can do.
And while you can train
on huge, huge data sets,
there are some
inherent properties
that make it so that it's
really, really local.
And there are these things
called activity cliffs
where changes happen very
dramatically in chemistry that
make active learning
and machine learning
very difficult to solve
problems like this.
So you might have
guessed that I was
going to give you a surprise.
This compound in the middle is
actually very, very soluble.
If you drop it in water
and it comes apart,
you can very effectively
deliver a drug
with this type of solubility.
So, why?
What's the difference here?
So the insoluble compound,
to understand it,
you have to go to 3D.
This is taking that
insoluble compound,
rendering it in 3D,
like it is in real life,
and then packing it into
a crystal, similar to how
water packs into ice crystals.
You can see all of
those blue connections
there between the different
copies of the molecule.
Those blue connections are
moderately energetically
favorable.
So if you have a bunch
of blue connections,
that might be enough to hold
something together, maybe not
forever but for a long time.
You can also see the
yellow connections.
Those are very, very
energetically favorable.
What that means
is that, with all
those yellow and
blue connections,
this molecule really
likes to hold onto itself.
It packs really well together.
And if it's packed
together, it's
not going to be tempted to
go swimming with water when
water comes around.
It's going to hold onto itself.
If you look at the
moderately soluble molecule,
you can kind of
get an idea for why
it is able to come
apart a little bit.
You'll see there are none
of those yellow lines that
were really, really strong.
All you have is the
blue lines, which is
a weaker type of interaction.
But there are enough
of those blue lines
that it still holds
together quite well.
So what you see when you take
the other molecule, which
we don't even have a good
crystal structure packing here,
is that you can't
really pack it in a way
where there's a lot of
good energetic connections.
There's many different
ways you could pack it,
but when it ends up that water
comes around, that there's so
few interactions, and
water is able to interact
with it favorably that it
just pulls it right out.
This is really hard to predict
with just 2D or 1D data.
And honestly, we've
run a bunch of ML
because we're interested in
machine learning a lot as well.
And even when you take 3D
data into consideration,
if you're not actively looking
at how the molecules can
twist and turn and
move with each other,
the simple 3D snapshot is just
not enough to predict this.
This has been your
science break, by the way.
I won't try to teach you
any more chemistry today,
but I figured it'd be
useful at some level
to understand what type of
properties we're talking about.
Now, that property,
solubility, it's pretty tough,
as I was just talking about.
It's actually relatively easy
because solubility, at least,
is only specific
to the molecule.
A lot of drug-like
properties are
how that drug molecule
reacts with giant proteins
or with other molecules that
are much harder to predict.
At least solubility, you're
only thinking about that one
molecule it's interacting with.
But it's also only one
of many, many properties
we have to optimize, and
all of those properties
have to be good.
If any of those properties
are bad, it will kill a drug.
And more evil than that is that,
not only are these properties
typically not correlated
at all, but some of them
are even anticorrelated.
So when you improve
a property, it's
guaranteed to make
another property worse.
So you're trying to find
this tightrope between two
properties where you can get
it right inside the range
of acceptability.
This is long,
laborious, tedious work,
and when every guess you
have about an improvement
on the molecule requires weeks
or months and tens of thousands
of dollars of synthesis,
it quickly adds up.
You can start to understand,
with the vastness of molecules,
how hard this guesswork
is and how expensive it
is to try a theory.
You can start to understand
why drug discovery is so hard.
I guess that's probably really
the end of the science lesson
here, but it is going to go
to compute soon, I promise.
So how is Schrodinger
solving this?
So we have a massive investment
in fundamental research.
That's something
we've really focused
on going all the way back.
We were founded by
Rich Friesner, who's
still at Columbia, in
the chemistry department
at Columbia, a professor.
And going all the way
back to the beginning,
we've really focused
on scientists.
We have over 100--
I think, actually, it's
over 150 PhD scientists
at this point who all they
do is try to figure out
how these fundamental physics
work on a chemical level
and how we can encode
that in our algorithms.
The next step from the science
is finding that perfect balance
of accuracy and speed.
And this is something
both our scientists
and a large engineering
force work very regularly on.
Sometimes that's as simple
as speeding up our code.
Sometimes, it's moving
things onto the GPU.
But sometimes, it's stepping
back and saying, on a chemical
level, what things can we take
for granted that will allow
us to simplify the algorithm?
It wouldn't be robust to
everything in the world,
but for this problem,
what can we simplify?
So we do a lot of that.
We do, luckily, scale
embarrassingly parallel.
Almost all of
these calculations,
since you're looking
at one drug at a time
and you might want to look at
batches of 10,000, that allows
you to scale up really, really
quickly as long as you have
the infrastructure to do so.
But the last one then
comes back around which
is, if you're
calculating information
on billions or tens
of billions or,
in the future, hundreds
of billions and trillions
of compounds, how
do you actually
deal with all that
data you're generating?
And that's a big
problem for us as well.
And how that works is,
on the very left phase,
we're looking at billions.
I think you can actually
go up to 10 to the 10th
at this point where
we're calculating
very fast properties on CPUs
for billions of compounds.
We use some machine learning
and some other simple algorithms
to get that down to
a small enough number
that we want to push
forward, and then we
start these cycles where
we improve the molecule,
we make guesses, we improve
our active learning.
Humans will evaluate
the designs,
humans will synthesize an
assay, and we'll slowly
be improving these properties.
The goal is to do this cycle
as few times as possible.
If you only had
to do it once, it
would be this dream world
where you could go from an idea
to a drug candidate going
into the clinic within weeks
or a few months.
That's the future dream.
Right now, even in the
best case scenario,
you're still doing
this cycle many times.
So those computing requirements
that I was referencing earlier.
What do those look like?
Well, we have massive
scale for CPU.
Maybe it's not massive
scale for Google,
but for most of us out
there, 500,000 CPUs
is a lot of CPUs to
be using at once.
That's more than a thousand to
a person working at our company,
to give you an
idea of that scale.
We also regularly
need a diverse GPU.
So the GPUs are
actually the workhorses
for our most important
calculations.
We have gotten relatively far
down the filter of accuracy
by the time we get to
the GPU calculations.
So we're doing a
lot fewer molecules,
which allows us to only maybe
have 10,000 things running
at once instead of 500,000
things running at once.
That said, it's
still a lot of work.
We are lucky that it's
relatively small input,
and the final output is still
relatively small in terms
of its terabytes.
If you were to keep track of
all the data we generate along
the way for those
predictions, it's
into the many, many
petabytes of data.
But luckily, we only
really need to save
some snapshots or
final snapshots
of these trajectories.
We don't have to keep
all the data together.
So relatively small
end on the order
of hundreds of megabytes
or gigabytes and then only
maybe terabytes.
So in the big sense of
the cloud, pretty small.
It's rich, dense data.
It's that small because we want
to analyze about everything.
It's not like the first step is
going and cleaning a bunch out.
We really do want to
look through pretty much
all of that data.
And then, finally, how are we
actually calculating things?
We have very different
requirements.
Sometimes, we need a GPU node
with only 12 gigs of memory
or even less, actually.
I think we have some
six gig instances.
And sometimes, we need
400 gigs on the GPU node,
so the ability that GCP has to
allow you to dynamically pick
your node size is really,
really powerful for us.
So here is an example of a
high-memory T4 GPU nodes.
So this is something that we
used to have to build in-house.
We actually originally
deployed this application
on an in-house server
because you simply
couldn't get something
with a few GPUs and 400
gigs of memory.
So I will go ahead
and play this video.
So what you're seeing here is
we've loaded about one and 1/2
billion compounds into the
GPU's memory as a subset.
We have the secondary
screening on the CPU
that allows us to keep a
relatively easy microservice,
if you will, that is
looking over a billion
synthesizable compounds.
And what we're doing
is we're saying,
those compounds on the right
are searching libraries
that you can just purchase
them off the shelf.
You don't have to
synthesize them,
which is a huge advantage
in early drug design.
And we're saying, OK, I'm
drawing my IDs on the left.
Find the closest thing
I can just purchase off
the shelf so we can guess
and experiment with our ideas
without having to invest
in custom synthesis, which
is very expensive.
So how are our strategies for
executing the big back end?
Not that microservice, but when
we're calculating properties
for these billions
down to thousands
of really expensive
calculations,
how do we handle that?
So first, we have the
hardest that we've done.
We have a team of really
good solution architects
and engineers that have
built a direct cloud API.
So that's how we've scaled up to
500,000 for a really long time.
We are developing
the technologies
to not have to use the
drug cloud API explicitly,
but for a lot of our massive
scale, we're still using that.
What we're moving to right
now is an auto-scaling queue
system.
I shouldn't say we're moving to.
As much stuff as we can
handle there, we will.
Slurm is our preferred
queuing system,
although, we support many.
It has some limitations
in somewhere
on the order of a couple
hundred thousand compute nodes.
But reaching that and
taking advantage of it,
there's a bunch of other legacy
stuff that you're reliant on.
That said, it's extremely
easy for some of our older
applications to
run on because they
were built to run on clusters
before the cloud existed.
The future that we're
building towards right
now is using Kubernetes,
and GKE specifically.
On the next slide, I'll go into
the architecture details there.
But we would really like
to see a world where
we can think about
things in GKE clusters
instead of having to
manually do cloud API.
And we're hoping GKE
will evolve to the place
where it can even
displace queuing systems
for a lot of those tasks.
The GKE setup that I
discussed a second ago--
so the way we're typically
doing that now is we're
using a Postgres server.
Now I should mention
that, when we
get to the point of
really crazy compute,
we'll almost certainly
replace that Postgres
server with BigQuery.
Right now, it's
just easy to deploy.
It also allows us to
deploy it in-house
if a customer were to have
in-house requirements.
The Postgres server and
the Kubernetes spinner
bring up nodes, and they
hit the Kubernetes API
server to bring up nodes.
We scale up to as many--
I forget the Kubernetes term.
We scale go to as many
Kubernetes nodes as we can.
And then, as that
work is finished,
it'll give status back
to the Postgres server,
maybe some very small number
of calculation numbers.
And it'll deposit the
files into buckets.
So the buckets will be used
for both input and output,
highly scalable data storage.
That's actually one really big
advantage over traditional HPC,
which frequently still
relies on things like NFS,
is the buckets are just really
high-quality scalable data
storage, and cheap.
So I wanted to stop a second
and say, what exactly are
those GPUs doing?
We're using 10,000 GPUs.
I've talked about
physics simulation,
but what does that look like?
Also, I just really
love these videos.
I think a lot of people
think they look cool,
so I figured I'd
show one of these.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So what this is right here is
it's a free energy perturbation
calculation.
I won't explain exactly
what that means,
but basically, that's
a drug molecule
that you're seeing with
waters hovering around it
inside a human protein.
And what we're
trying to figure out
is if we take a drug
molecule where we already
know its efficacy, and we make
a small perturbation to it,
will it be more effective
as a drug molecule?
Will it bind better
to the protein?
This calculation
requires-- here it
says eight hours of GPU time.
I think the video's
a few hours old,
and we have it down to something
like two to four hours of GPU
time, thanks a lot to NVIDIA
for speeding up their GPUs.
But it takes hours on a
GPU to do this simulation
for a single ligand.
[END PLAYBACK]
And again, go back to that
10 to the 60th drug space.
You can see how infinite the
compute would be to calculate
this for all available ligands.
So simulating just that simple
motion, those motion mechanics,
is quite expensive,
and we do what we
can to reduce it when we can.
So that's how we keep one
GPU busy for that one.
But coming up with ideas, how
do we come up with so many ideas
to keep all those GPUs busy?
Well, it might kind of look like
motion because it's so blurred,
but what this actually is it's
thousands and thousands of drug
molecules superpositioned
on top of each other,
preserving the same
core in the bottom.
So those are all tiny,
tiny changes up top.
And we've enumerated many,
many potential drug molecules
that we think might be good.
We've taken a lot
of the human work
out of individually drawing
them by enumerating a bunch
of different combinations.
And once we've done
that, now we say,
OK, we have this
big group of ones.
Let's run some subset
of these through
the physics-based
engine on the GPU.
So say we've enumerated a
billion like I was referencing.
Let's filter it down.
Let's run a thousand through
GPUs for several hours,
maybe 10,000 for GPUs
for several hours.
And then when we
get that data back,
let's train an active
learning algorithm.
That active learning
algorithm will then
take a guess at another thousand
values and just sporadically
pick points that are
either good or bad
or maybe just interesting
for other ideas
and run the physics
calculation on those.
And that's how we
extend the applicability
domain of active learning.
Active learning is
really good in this space
for interpolation.
When you have two things
that are just clearly
two steps apart from each
other, active learning
is pretty good at finding
the point in between them.
It's not perfect because
sometimes there's
surprise physics.
We still always double-check
active learning,
but it's really good.
The thing that active learning
isn't great at in this space
is finding truly novel things.
When you come up with new
chemistry that is just
going to totally change the
way the physics and the protein
works, active
learning just can't
guess that because it's never
seen that physics in existence
before with the protein.
So that's where, for
extrapolation, you really
have to constantly
be running more
physics-based calculations.
So once we've generated
all that data,
what do we actually do with it?
Let's step back to the beginning
of drug discovery project,
and a biologist has
discovered a protein
that they're pretty sure is
strongly related to a disease.
So they've done some
lab experiments,
and if they knock
out that protein,
the disease goes away in the
lab, not in a human being,
maybe in a mouse.
So let's kick off
a project trying
to find molecules that could
knock out that protein.
And maybe those molecules
could end up being drugs.
How do we actually do that?
How much data's involved?
And that's what this
slide's talking about here.
We probably want to
start with something
on the order of 10
billion new ideas.
We want to do either
high-throughput screening
in the lab where they have
some special machines that
spin a bunch of
fragments through, allow
you to get some really
inaccurate coarse data just
to start off of.
Or if you're pretty
confident with what you have
on the computer-- it's called
an X-ray crystal structure,
3D data of the protein--
you can start to do
virtual screening
with just the computer
itself, without having
to go to the lab.
People go back and forth
on these two things.
They're both fairly
inaccurate, but they find you
the starting places
you need to proceed.
But the problem is, say, you've
calculated these 20 properties
for 10 billion things, what
do you actually do with this?
Keep in mind, this is
not a computer scientist.
They're usually not
even data scientists.
This is just a chemist
that has picked up
computers over the
years as they've had to,
and we're talking about them
having to deal with parsing up
to trillions of data points.
So this is where GCP's
BigQuery has really
been a game changer for us.
We're able to set it up that
our back ends can deposit
the most important data
directly into BigQuery,
and people who aren't
necessarily data scientists
are able to interact
with that data.
So BigQuery has given us
a lot of great things.
So in this example that
you're seeing, we have loaded,
very easily, 1.2
billion molecules--
you can see the
number of rows here--
and a bunch of data
about it into BigQuery.
Now normally, if we were doing
this, these terabytes of data
would require a
nontrivial IT task.
We'd have to set up a
database for the user.
These would have to figure
out how to interact with it.
We'd have to pick a UI that the
user could easily figure out,
and it wouldn't scale very
well unless we really were
committed to making this great.
But with BigQuery,
as you just saw,
you can execute this really
simple query, this basic five
drug-like properties
query, and it
will happen almost immediately
in just a few seconds.
So the scalability
is like, we care
more about the output
of this than anything
else we could care about
from a database perspective.
And it doesn't require
very much for the chemist
to get going on it,
so it really has
allowed us to think about data
in a totally different way.
This example shows how
complex we can get.
The first one was very simple,
but this example shows us the--
again, with 1.2 billion, we've
created this really complex
query.
And what we're
really trying to do
is sort things into
different classes.
So we've loaded 1.2
billion new molecules
in with all of their
data, and now we
have this query that
allows us to sort those
into different things.
So you can see here,
in just 5.2 seconds,
we've sorted 1.2
billion molecules
into different
classes of molecules,
whether they're their
drug-like or fragments
or things like that.
The ability to do
that essentially
immediately is just an
absolute game changer
for our data scientists.
So the last really
big GCP feature for us
is not nearly as fashionable as
machine learning or large scale
HPC or even big data.
Honestly, it matters a
lot for us, especially
from the management IT
side, security side.
We just love the
project layout of GCP.
The isolation is
very, very natural.
The user access
management is great.
It gives you a lot of options,
sometimes, too many options,
but it's better to have
too many than too few.
And especially, if you're
a corporate G Suite user,
it's just trivial to move
people into a GCP-type cloud
interface.
I personally find the
interface wonderful,
both the web UI and
the command line tools.
I don't get enough time to do
purely technical stuff anymore,
so if the interface is
really easy to learn,
I'm much more likely
to use the tool.
And I find both interfaces
to be really, really strong.
I'm not going to give a bunch of
examples here of the interface.
People can play with it
themselves, but I did
want to highlight
that because that
was a really big part of
the reason why we chose
GCP, just the ease of use.
It's enjoyable both for naive
users and the DevOps experts.
So to give the summary
here, Schrodinger's
computational chemistry platform
can speed up drug discovery,
and sometimes that's
actually directly
correlated to
computational throughput.
Sometimes, it's blocked by
lab work and things like that,
but there are significant
parts of a project runtime
where, if I just
have the ability
to run more
computations at once,
I will speed up how fast
the drug goes to market.
And it can literally
be day for day.
So if something that used
to take 10 days and it
takes two days,
that means you get
to that clinical stage
eight days faster,
and it's eight days faster
that drug gets to market.
It's pretty amazing
when you think
about being able to
speed up tasks like that,
and the cloud has helped a lot.
GCP, specifically for all
the reasons I've listed,
makes our discovery
efforts faster.
It makes it more flexible,
and that flexibility directly
translates into getting
things done faster.
BigQuery allows our scientists
to store and analyze data.
It's funny we're talking
about it in the same sentence
because it seems like a
totally separate tool,
but the way it integrates so
well with everything GCP's
doing, and how we can reach it
from all of our compute nodes
trivially-- it has great
access controls and all
of that-- that integrated
nature of BigQuery
really has been a game
changer when we're analyzing
the big data we generate.
So all in summation,
these tools come together
to make GCP just a complete
solution for Schrodinger that
sped us up, and we've
really invested in.
And then on that note, I'm
going to go to the cool video.
I love to show these.
Again, I mentioned earlier,
I think people just
like to think about how
molecules work inside your body
even if you're not a scientist.
And we've done a pretty good job
of making these things pretty.
So here's a video that's
a few years old that I'll
end the presentation on.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[SWOOSH]
[MUSIC - THE
CINEMATIC ORCHESTRA,
"ARRIVAL OF THE BIRDS"]
[END PLAYBACK]
PATRICK LORTON: And I
will end it on that note.
Thank you very much
for watching today.
I hope I didn't bore you
too much with science.
There's a ton of people I
should thank, by the way.
A bunch of our solution
architects helped this out,
and obviously, the whole company
built most of the software.
Thank you very much.